and without further ado team 19 now I'll
turn 18 19 project is called both
imminent and we wanted you to join us on
our journey our promise how can we
create greater access to steam
opportunities we have passionate about
reframing st e m2 F T a.m. to Steve and
authentic an integrated way of
approaching these disciplines into our
curriculum we've thought about access in
two key ways access to resources for
communities and student and access to
curriculum resources for educators we
created a mobile learning lab to allow
for mobility of resources and to
integrate building bridges to bring
learning to the community through
connecting classroom experiences put
real life experiences in this way didn't
become researchers and experts for
example in a unit of France student
could collect data about growing paint
pots to hold their plan and represents
this data graphically to share with a
larger audience educators often struggle
with embedding integrating steam
activities into typical routine because
they haven't run that way themselves and
they don't have time to develop the idea
because teachers would learn alongside
students in this mobile lab they would
experience learning a concept in an
integrative way to conquer the issue of
developing ideas part of our
professional development would be to
create time for participant adult to
create new steam experiences that would
then be held in our cloud repository all
resources will be available to all
participants and to incentivize use of
the cloud to uploading and downloading
new units and project will use badging
and discount for the bus so what does it
look like an implementation our data
comm approximately twenty thousand
dollars would find out and budget into
the purchase of a youth box 10,000 to
staffing five thousand outfitting this
bus we would fun way from local
businesses and philanthropy our ongoing
overhead to cover stamping maintenance
and turnover a bus contact some of
overhead can be covered through fees to
bring a back to your community as well
as continued fundraising and grams we
would sky by bringing forth team ahead
to Phoenix Arizona and then scale
through key point in air gonna and
hopefully across multiple state from
there alright he's so much question that
was sort of a random selection we found
a website that ranked some of the most
depressed districts in the country and I
just scanned it really quickly and
they're worried a lot of Arizona know
why is the bus essential to this model
mobility we really focused on trying to
meet people wherever they were so bring
the resources in case they don't have a
space in their school or if there are
spaces are rigid this would allow a
little bit of flexibility hopefully the
teachers have been so inspired by the
process that they're uploading materials
to the online repository so that they'll
continue to teach in that way I think
another key idea about the bus that I
wanted to share that we thought it
having the bus actually be part of this
team experience so we were thinking if
we could get a bucket to buy a bus or
donate about you could then work with a
local community college to help us
convert this Buster that it can be run
on vegetable oil for I'm diesel or
something like that if a botany
maintenance then we could bring it to
maybe a Vocational Technical College and
they could work on the maintenance what
the device itself is both bringing
access literally but also serving a
vehicle for the light it's a steam
project the bus itself is a steamer how
would you select where to go first no
not Arizona but if you have a lot of
schools in Arizona wanted to have a day
so what are you select which would be
the right crowd in which school I think
the easiest thing to do so one of the
things I really like about the box is
that it offers the opportunity to do
sort of my cross networking sure you
could garlic best day with a project at
elementary school then take the bus to
the miracle then to high school so i
would actually focus on a school that
has really good vertical alignment so
you could start showing people how this
but could build community bolt
within a district but also within
teachers fennekin what about the free
time of the bus nobody's using it what
you are gonna do he's gonna want to be
using it all the time something okay
good